hey everyone nikki bowers here i am the
social media and marketing producer
for eight news now and i am here joined
with this beautiful couple
their name is howard and danielle taylor
and they are
certified marriage experts
and they are here because it is
valentine's day we all know it's around
the corner
and we all know that we have been stuck
at home
and so they want to give us some tips
mostly the married couples
give you guys some tips on what you can
do
to continue to have that little spark
with each other continue to have that
little romance
even though y'all are probably about to
kill each other because you see each
other all the time
so imma toss it on over to danielle and
howard
welcome hi hello thank you for having me
guys no chorus thank you for being here
so as i was saying in the intro
we've all been working from home
majority of us have been working from
home
so a lot of couples are seeing more of
each other than they're used to seeing
and i know that that can be a little
tense at times
because you don't really have that
escape you know the women don't we don't
have that escape with our girlfriends
the guys don't really have that escape
with their guys to you know be out
and about because we're all kind on
still on lockdown because of the
pandemic
so what do you guys what do you suggest
what do you have to say to couples
who maybe are thinking of foregoing
valentine's day this year because
they're with each other anyway and
they're probably just
tired of each other listen we would
first say don't do it don't for
don't forgo the holiday that's dedicated
towards
towards love you know um justifiably so
couples have been on top of each other
2020 was a
trying year for so many um as we go into
2021
danielle and i for our own marriage are
making sure we're intentional about
staying connected and
in in order to stay connected in
marriage and relationship
you have to be purposeful and
intentional about doing so that you have
to put
actions to your intent so we just want
to share
five tips that we we have utilized in
our own marriage
right helping us feel the love before
february 14th
so uh we we would love to share a few of
them one of them
helped with the with the being on top of
each other right
the suffocation we got a tip for you too
but the first one that we like to say is
uh have a spa night within your home
plan an
after hour spa night make sure the kids
are in bed if you have children
and use your space this home that's
became
monotonous our house is an office it's
an elementary school it's your
area and everything take this space and
begin to redefine it and create a spa
a spa night um it's so fun
and and romantic and invigorating to our
relationship for us to pull out those
massage oils do the bubble bath
do the candles and just recreate the
space you know we're better masseuse
today than we ever were pre pandemic
listen massage classes are just a
youtube away so
definitely plan an after hours massage
night and spa night for sure
okay the second tip since howard
mentioned
to do the youtube class is to go on
youtube and find
a class what's on of the online interest
of mutual interest
go online and find a class of mutual
interest so howard and i did that
and the thing that we learned how to do
was a tango
and a salsa class which we usually do at
night you know we're like winding down
putting the kids
eating dinner that type of thing so to
spark it up and go on there and do
something fun and laugh and just you
know do something spontaneous was really
interesting
so whether it's an art class a language
class like french or spanish or dance
just go on and find something that you
can do
together that will help you guys like
shake it up a little
and and also by you all doing tango and
salsa it brings you a cloak
you know that's right no line dancing do
some
pain dancing yeah
okay what else you got for us oh so
another one
and let's just jump right into this one
this one is the one that will help
couples like we talked about
doing spa nights and doing the class of
mutual interest
interest one important one is penciling
in me time
uh penciling in me time is essential to
staying connected you know when i was
raised my mom used to always sell now
howard
time apart makes the heart grow fonder
and it's it's so true and so
in the time where we've been in the
house together make sure to allow your
wife on the weekends to me
maybe step away or your husband to do a
bike ride or
you know be be purposeful about getting
that on schedule because if you don't
get it on schedule your personal me time
throughout the week
it probably won't materialize just like
in the professional world if you don't
put something on schedule you'll plug
something in
yeah and and i know with my wife who's
as incredible of the woman she is
we're men that we have two sons she's
managing our kids during the day
and she definitely needs her me time for
sure
she does she's superwoman she needs that
meantime absolutely
absolutely i appreciate it as well um
the next tip is kind of like
it's interesting but it's fun at the
same time which is to recreate your vows
or your proposal so last year marriages
were under attack a lot of people were
kind of butting heads starting to get to
know each other and realize you know
there are parts of us that we don't
quite like right
so what a better way to come together to
recommit yourselves mentally to go back
to why you fell in love in the first
place and redo your vows
redo your proposal some women didn't
like their proposal so now's
the time to recreate this and and have
an amazing experience
now with that though could you do you
think you would offend your spouse by
saying you know i didn't i really didn't
like that proposal
so let's do it again like how do you how
do you do it in a way where you don't
offend
your spouse well you know you have to be
careful there it's not for the woman to
say
i wasn't exactly thrilled the last time
you didn't give me the story i was
looking for so let's redo this thing
however i think if you wreck if you do a
recommendation and say you know we've
been through a lot the last year was
tough
let's just recreate our vowels maybe it
might give the guy an idea
well listen this tip should be for the
fellas
let's just cut across the grass all the
gentlemen listening out there
you take the initiative and recreate
uh your proposal even if it was
incredible coming off of 2020 who
doesn't want a fresh start right
i i i had a i felt like a romantic
proposal
but heck i would propose to danielle
every day over now
rewriting the vowels isn't offensive so
you know on that side maybe a suggestion
hey i would i'm rewriting my vowels for
my hubby yeah and presenting that on
valentine's day
yeah okay and so for people who want to
recreate the proposal
you know not everyone i think a lot of
people will recreate it and maybe go get
another ring or
something or you know a little gift or
something what would you suggest for
someone who maybe
is not financially able to upgrade a
ring or do something like that what
would you
suggest like that they can do or give in
that moment of recreating that proposal
i think it's not even about the ring
it's not about the material it's about
the intent behind the heart
you know a recommitment of your love a
recommitment of things maybe that have
been fallen short in the past
things that have been difficult for
couples to say going forward
this is going to be a positive year for
us this is going to be a year of
excellence and fun
and love and passion and peace so if
it's not buying a gift
it's a love letter it's a cooking
something for them relieving them of
their chores like just showing your love
in some type of way
that is is separated is different than
what you did yesterday is different than
what you did last year just an
environment and a feeling of this is
something new going forward it's a new
day and you have a new me
that i'm committed to being a better
person than i was before
even if you're a great husband or a
great wife you can always improve on who
you are
and so i think that's more where the
intent is rather than like
oh i'm expecting a new ring or a
bracelet or something fancy
you know okay i like that i like that i
agree i agree
what else you guys got so you know
in los angeles we have been under
very strong sanctions and we have been
able to go to our favorite restaurants
you know you think about
valentine's day coming out one of the
typical things for valentine's day
that standard is going to your favorite
fine dining restaurant so what day on i
decided to do this year
and we're planning to recreate our
favorite restaurant dish
in our house now this is for recreation
for two so again the kids have to go to
sleep
don't tell the kids what you're cooking
if they smell what you're cooking just
tell them this is for mommy and daddy
because it's a reservation for two
look up on google or and or youtube
we've given youtube a lot of shouts out
but look up online you can find your fa
most of your favorite restaurant menus
and so what it allows you to do is have
a fun time just recreating it right
we're not the biggest culinary people in
the world but everybody looks forward to
their favorite dish
and then make it make it romantic at
home for the holiday season so if you
can't go out bring that fine dining
restaurant to your house
we always see romantic comedies where
the guy has on the apron
and he's you know he's serving the plate
at the table
now make that make that i i guess i'm
saying that fantasy reality these are
things that you truly could do in your
marriage that just
makes it exciting and so we suggest that
people bring your favorite restaurant
to your house i love that i love that
so do you all have anything else that
you can suggest for the um
married couples did we hit them all
no we we had them all but if you get
them all you have more ideas
okay so i have a question i'm not
married
i don't even have a significant other
right now so what
what is the suggestion that you have for
someone like myself who's single
who what is your suggestion for me to
make sure that i celebrate myself
and loving myself on valentine's day
if i can't let's say get a a reservation
at a restaurant
okay i think to to enjoy yourself on
valentine's day
i think you should pamper yourself i
think you should go out and buy yourself
something nice
i it doesn't undermine the holiday if
you send yourself flowers if you give
yourself candy that doesn't undermine it
because you love yourself and you're
worth it
i think you and your girls should get
together you guys can rent out a movie
theater
and just watch a movie all by yourself a
romantic comedy
select theaters are allowing people to
run out the whole entire theater for a
very reasonable price point
um another idea that you can do is get
all your friends on a zoom call whether
you're male or female get all your
friends on a zoom call and invite a
comedian on
to oh you know that's a good idea
thank you split the cost and make
everybody have a fun night for sure
right i like that that's a good idea
thank you
so much now for the for the go ahead
don't say for the friends out there
you got to put in on the comedian cost
this is all about
zoom call comedy club right right right
now for the the um couples out there
like you all who have
children um
do you have like any tips for them of
what they can do for the kids
so that they have their own little
special valentine's day and won't be
trying to impede on yours or do you
suggest them just doing everything while
the babies are asleep no
so kids i dan and i have two boys as we
mentioned earlier and we love
doing arts and crafts with our kids so
art arts and crafts because children
can't go to amusement parks they can't
go
go to places that they're typically used
to for going through so i i would say
that uniquely every holiday could be a
family holiday in so
so many ways now we for sure advocate
for carving out just
time for you and your significant other
but for sure make valentine's day the
the the day of love for the entire
family because i'll tell you
love is not exclusive obviously to yeah
as dale alluded to earlier self-love is
probably one of the best things that any
of us can have
to enhance our families and enhance our
marriages so
leveling those kids on valentine's day
too let's think outside the box and make
the whole day worth
worth love i could tell you the final
thing i'll say is when i was in
elementary school we used to have all
the little valentine's day
cards and secret cars that i think they
called them the love grams or whatever
and so
let's still make it special for the kids
for sure oh i love that i love that you
guys had some really really great ideas
do me a favor tell everyone where they
can find you i know you all have a show
and then i know you also have social
media channels and if you have a website
please tell everyone where they can find
you okay
so our website is www.marriageondeck.com
we have the marriage on deck show that
airs on tuesday and thursday on the
christian television network
at 3 and 5 30 central standard time
and our social media handles are also
marriage on deck
and then our book the fundamentals of
marriage can be purchased at our website
or on amazon.com
awesome and and real quick what do you
talk about in the book just give like
everyone a little snippet so they
would be you know interested to go out
and get it for sure so our book is
called the fundamentals of marriage
eight essential practices of successful
couples and so in that book
out of our life experience and coaching
hundreds of couples we talk about
everything from communication
how to maximize it how to learn your
spouse's language
to finance to the four factors of
forgiveness
so we take eight essential elements that
are successful
for marriage and we put him into this
workbook what's unique about it is that
it's not just a novel read there's
tips in there there's discussion
questions there's personal reflections
in this book
um there's case studies there's a his
and her section where daniel
and i go into the depths of our
perspective
towards the particular subject matter
and so i would tell you that it is a
workbook it's very active and it's a
tool whether you're single
whether you're seriously dating or
engaged or whether you're married
awesome and would you suggest that
couples do it together unfortunately
absolutely
yeah yeah i think that we would say you
read chapter one about purpose
and i think you it would have got you
awesome
well howard and danielle you all are
awesome
howard and danielle taylor you all make
sure you go check them out on
ctn for their marriage on debt
is that what it's called marriage on
deck show their marriage on debt show
and also follow them on their social
channels
they give great advice everything you
need
to make sure that you are staying
connected
and staying close to one another even
though
we're all on top of each other doing
this pain damage right
so thank you so much you all for being
doing this interview with us